[موسيقى]
يعد نادي هيريتاج للغولف أحد
أشهر وجهات ممارسة رياضة الجولف في الجزيرة،
فهو يشتمل على ملعبين كاملين بمساحة 18 ساعة
في محفظته، وملعب
Link Style L Reserve الذي تم افتتاحه مؤخرًا وملعب
L chatau الأكثر رسوخًا، وهو جزء من
مجموعة رائعة جدًا من الملاعب الموجودة
على  الجزيرة بأكملها، الوجهة
رائعة للجولف، لدينا الآن 11
ملعبًا للجولف مكونة من 18 حفرة، وثلاثة ملاعب جولف بها تسع حفر،
لذا يوجد الكثير من ألعاب الجولف في
منطقة صغيرة والجودة جيدة حقًا،
انظر إلى هذه الملاعب الخضراء، نعم،
ملعب مذهل  الذي تراه هنا هو
ملعب L chatau للجولف وأود أن أصفه
بأنه ملعب باركلاندز استوائي،
وعادةً ما يحتوي على الكثير من أشجار النخيل ولكن
كل حفرة مختلفة، أخبرنا
المزيد عن L Reserve لأنه
جديد تمامًا، والبعض يقول إنه  إنه أمر
صعب للغاية، حيث يوجد بعض
الماء في الملعب، لذا فهو ليس
ملعب Lynx نموذجيًا للجولف، ومن
أول T إلى الحفرة الثامنة عشر، يوجد تغيير في الارتفاع بمقدار 200 متر،
لذا فهو يتمتع بروابط معاصرة مرتبطة
بأسلوب الارتباط، لذا فإن
لعبة الجولف مختلفة جدًا  الدورات التدريبية تحصل على أفضل ما في
العالمين هنا في منتجعات هيريتدج
ولا تحتاج حقًا إلى مغادرة المنتجع،
فلاعب الجولف في الجنة هنا، لذا لنتحدث عن [
الموسيقى]،
فإننا نواصل التركيز على الشباب،
ونحن سعداء جدًا لأننا  لدينا حوالي
1600 ترخيصًا، وهو ما يزيد قليلاً عن ذلك الذي
زاد خلال
العامين الماضيين لحوالي 100 لاعب غولف كل عام
أه فيما يتعلق بالتراخيص، سنستمر
في النمو على ما أعتقد لأن
لعبة Go تنمو بشكل عام، لدينا
مشروع في  خط أنابيب مع مجموعة MCB
التي تعد الراعي الرئيسي لنا
وشريكنا لهذا العام ونأمل أن نتمكن من
التقدم معًا لنجعل
لعبة الجولف للناشئين أفضل ولماذا لا يكون لدينا
بطل ماران في غضون
عامين، حيث تتمتع العديد من البنوك الكبرى في ماريوس
بروابط قوية  بالنسبة
للعبة، أعتقد أننا شاركنا في لعبة
الجولف مع جولة Elders the Legends مع
أه ودي ولكننا نعتقد
أن تواجدنا مع Juniors
ربما يروج للجيل القادم
ونأمل أن يكون لدينا أحد
لاعبي الغولف في جولة PGA  يومًا ما، هذا
هو الهدف وأعتقد أن لدينا
مواهب جيدة حقًا في ماسيوس، وهناك
الكثير من الأماكن الجميلة للعب الجولف، ولهذا
السبب نريد أن نكون هناك
وأعتقد أنه بالنسبة للصغار، فإن قضاء
الوقت على العشب الأخضر هو الأفضل  من القيام
بشيء
آخر